Musik Nicht für uns, sondern für den lieben Max Nummer elf. Eins bis zehn waren schon weg, Nummer elf. Max ist so generischer Name, da muss man sich Musiken rein. Max Nummer elf. These, je generischer der Vorname, desto mehr sucht man Distinktionsmerkmale, wie zum Beispiel Musik machen. Ich will es nicht, ich will es nicht. Ich dachte, es ist ein trockenes Referat. Okay, alles klar. Knochen, trockenes Referat. Staubiges, alles klar, ich spiele es nicht, ich spiele es nicht. Ich dachte, du spritt es. Es ist ein trockenes Referat, Knochen-Trockenes Referat. Okay, staubiges, alles klar, ich habe es falsch interpretiert. Wenn du so heisst, bei dir verstehe ich es nicht, aber Stefan, natürlich muss man da irgendwas machen, um sich vor allen anderen abzuheben. Wenn du Max heisst, mach ich elf noch dazu, dann bist du wie eine Zahl. Du bist nur einer von vielen. Und dann muss man was machen wie Musik. Ja, ich finde bei Zahlen ist es immer so schwierig, wenn man sich denkt, warum hast du nicht einen drüber genommen, warum nicht einen drunter, also warum nicht Max 10, Max 12, warum genau nicht 11, ich habe ihn auch so genannt, aber man könnte natürlich auch sagen, es ist römisch zweit, Max der zweite, weiß ich nicht. Mich schreiben tatsächlich ab und zu Leute an, die sagen, ich habe ein Kind bekommen, also ich hatte Sex und jetzt habe ich ein Kind, richtig? Ich habe meine potenten Samen hineingeschleudert, viel zu viele. In meine wunderschöne Frau, die diese willig aufgenommen hat in sich und daraus durch das Wunder der Natur und die Wunder des Sexes Ja, Wunder der Natur, aber primär Wunder meiner Potenz ist ein Kind entstanden und jetzt überlegen wir, ob wir das Florentin nennen. So, dann fragen mich Leute, kannst du den Namen empfehlen? Und das ist natürlich keine leichte Frage zu beantworten, weil ich kenne natürlich keinen anderen Namen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es ist. Kennst du keinen anderen Florentin? Nee, also man googelt sich ja manchmal selbst und kommt dann natürlich … Komisch gestellt, die Frage. Kennst du nicht keinen anderen, der nicht den Namen Florentin trägt? Ich kenne eigentlich niemanden, der nicht Florentin heisst. Ja, ich hoffe nicht. Aber es natürlich schwer zu beantworten, weil man denkt sich, ja, ist schon ein besonderer Name und du wirst oft Florian genannt oder Florentin anders ausgenommen, du wirst oft als weiblich wahrgenommen, wenn es nur um den Namen geht. Also das ist ja wie, du hast ja nur die Experience mit diesem einen Namen. Ja. Du kennst ja nicht dein Leben neu starb mit einem anderen Namen. Ja. Da habe ich gedacht, es wäre so schlimm, wenn es im echten Leben, weil man kennt das ja manchmal, wenn man in Computerspiele muss man vorher Namen auswählen. Ja. Und dann weiss man nicht, dass das ganze Spiel in Caps stattfindet. Richtig. Dann hat man so ein Lower Caps Name oder Stefan, wo nur das S gross ist. Habe ich immer so gemacht. Ja. Und dann ist das ganze Spiel in Caps. Ja, oder aus Spaß nennst du dich irgendwie Tittenstefan und dann irgendwie, oh, edler Held, von dem die Prophezeiung seit jeher spricht, Tittenstephan, endlich seid ihr hier. Und dann denkst du dir, war das so eine gute Idee, so witzig ist es auch nicht mehr. Ja, vor allem weil die Immersion, also irgendwann ist man ja dieser holde Held. Ja, ja, ja. Der geht flöten, wenn man die ganze Zeit Tittenstephan angesprochen hat. Das geht wirklich, wir sind flöten. Und für mich ist es auch so, weil ich lese halt ständig diesen ulkigen Namen Florentin. Und ich weiß gar nicht, also ich fühle mich so verantwortlich für dieses noch entstehende Kind, diese Persönlichkeit, weil natürlich macht es was mit dir, wenn du einen besonderen Namen hast, aber es ist natürlich, man steht natürlich auch im Mittelpunkt. Du wirst im Wadezimmer als Frau Will gerufen und dann stehst du auf und die Leute lachen sich kaputt. Die hauen sich auf teilweise gebrochene Oberschenkel im Arzt, im Wadezimmer und dann denkt man natürlich, ja, ist okay und dann, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, ich bin jetzt nicht das erste Mal so. Florentin, aber ich verstehe nicht genau, warum das weiblich gelesen wird. Ist ja wie Valentin. Naja, es gibt ja das mit E-Endung Florentin. Ja, es gibt auch Steffi oder Stefanie. Ja, aber du heisst ja nicht Stefanie. Du heisst auch nicht Florentine. Naja, aber das liest man eben manchmal so, man denkt es eh mit. So Josephine oder so halt was Französisches. Ich finde es einen wunderschönen Namen. Denkt man sehr einfach. Und ich würde sofort sämtliche Kinder, also Endresultate meines Sexes nach deinem … Mein verlängertes Glied quasi. Genau. Mein in die Welt hinaus ragendes, enormes Glied. Würde ich nach dir benennen. Oh, Moment. Du würdest dein Kind nach mir benennen? Das hast du jetzt gesagt? Nee. In Folge des Podcast-Uvo-Podcast-Projekts? Naja, eigentlich habe ich diesen Satz nur angefangen, wegen dieses Gags mit dem Sex wieder. Und dann habe ich danach... Aber jetzt hast du es gesagt. Ja, jetzt hast du es gesagt. Ja und, wir haben noch nie irgendwas gemacht, von dem wir gesagt haben. Falls ihr ein Kind wollt und keinen Samen zur Verfügung habt, schreibt Stefan gerne mal an, es leitet in die Instagram-DMs, er kann euch gerne ein Paket zuschicken. Only Fans, so only semen. Only semen. Er kann euch gerne ein Paket zuschicken und dann könnt ihr da einen herrlichen Acht mit verbringen. Oh, hast du das mit dieser Doku gesehen? Der Mann der tausend Kinder? Ja, ja, ja. Das ist so unglaublich gruselig. Es geht um einen Mann, der hat sich auf Samenbanken angemeldet und da ist man eh schon begrenzt. Aber war das nicht der Arzt? Es gibt mehrere Geschichten. Es gibt einmal den Arzt, der einfach gesagt hat, anstatt irgendwelchen anderen Leuten nehme ich immer meinen Samen und der einfach tausende Kinder hatte dann am Ende. Es gibt auch den Holländern. Genau, ich glaube, er ist Däne, aber er war vor allem in Holland aktiv oder so. Jedenfalls hat er auf mehreren Websites war er gelistet und was ich nicht wusste, Holland hat diese Regel, dass ein Mann nur 25 Mal spenden darf. Also ein Mann darf nur 25 Mal, ne, privat ist das so eine Grauzone. Eigentlich schon auch. Banken sollten das regulieren und man soll es ja eigentlich nur bei Banken machen, das ist der einzige Weg. Also klar, du kannst Frauen nicht verbieten oder dem Mann nicht verbieten. Du kannst auch einfach im öffentlichen Schwimmbad schwimmen. Also es gibt ja Möglichkeiten. Ja, oder in einen Whirlpool gehen, in irgendeinen Whirlpool gehen. Ja, und dann hat er das wirklich so übertrieben, dass die Banken haben es auch nicht so richtig kontrolliert, dass er bei sehr vielen Spendebanken war und regelmäßig gespendet hat und dann auch privat und sich unter verschiedenen Namen auf verschiedenen Websites, die teilweise aus Listen bestimmen mit hunderten Namen, die aber alle er waren im Kern und hat sich dann immer getroffen. Und was war der Antrieb? Also hat er auch da was gesagt, was sein Antrieb war? Ja genau, dann hat er die ganze Zeit einen YouTube-Channel, wo er durch die Welt reist und so Videos erklärt, wo er ein bisschen über sich erzählt und was er so denkt. Und er hat so eine Ansprache, wie er immer sagt, ihr da draußen, macht's doch wie ich, bla bla bla. Und die checkt man aber nicht so richtig, diese Videos. Und irgendwann, die sind aber der Anlass dazu, dass man denkt, oh, der reist aber ganz schön viel rum. Ah ja. Ah krass, wo hat er das Geld, so viel rumzureisen, weil so viele Views hat er auch gar nicht. Und dann wurden die Frauen skeptisch und dann sind in den ganzen Ländern, in anderen Ländern ist der gleiche Typ aufgetaucht, dann haben die sich bei Facebook, die Mütter sich, und das Ding ist, die meisten Mütter, die einen Spendemann gesucht haben, also die meisten Paare, die einen Spendemann gesucht haben, wollten dann ja irgendwann gerne, weil die meisten haben ja zwei Kinder, wollten also noch ein zweites Kind und sind auch wieder auf ihn zugekommen. Das heißt, es hat sich so exponentiell, ist es grösser geworden und die Angst vor Inzest, ungewolltem Inzest, ist ja daraus resultiert diese 25 Mal in Holland, weil Holland ist ein kleines Land. Dass wenn eins dieser Kinder wiederum mit dem gleichen Samen dann ist ... So, und dann gibt es wirklich dieses Phänomen, dass sich Leute, also Kinder, die eine sehr, sehr gleiche DNA haben, neigen, sich anzufreunden.
Da gibt es Studien, die das belegen.
Und dann gab es wirklich den Fall, dass sich zwei Mütter am Spielplatz, da haben die Kinder sehr schnell miteinander eine gute Ebene gehabt, haben sich angefreundet, war noch ganz klein aber, und dann haben sie darüber gesprochen und dann ja Spender, ah ich auch, krass, ja aus dem Internet, ja ich auch, krass und dann war das der gleiche tatsächlich. Und es ging sehr, sehr schnell. Und dann so wurde dann daraus eine Facebook-Gruppe und immer mehr Leute, ja und dann diese Videos und es wurden immer mehr Leute und irgendwann war diese Zahl so unüberschaubar, dass man gecheckt hat, für wen er diese Videos macht. Für seine Kinder. Verstehe. Und dann wirkt es plötzlich so Preaching-mässig. Und dann habe ich so gedacht, das ist so krass, weil verrückte Autokraten versuchen, die Welt zu erobern. Macht, alles schreben nach Macht. Es ist so leichter, aber er hat das ja durchspielt. Genghis Khan hat auch seine Gene weit verbreitet, aber halt durch Gewalt, wohingegen der Däne ist einfach nur durch Bürokratie. Aber wie viele Kinder hatte Genghis Khan dann am Ende? Nicht so, ja, wahrscheinlich viele. Wie viele Kinder hatte der Krieg konkret? Stefan, du drängst mich hier gerade in eine historische Ecke, aus der ich mich nicht mehr hinaus meine Brie sagen wir wie viele kinder jengis khan hat keine ahnung wenn du der fucking khan bist der mann war khan jengis khan und jengis khan der war khan so er hat einfach jedes jeden zweiten tag wahrscheinlich ein kind gezeugt irgendwo und Und der war alt, der war alt. Und Kahn. Und Kahn.
Und Kahn und Kahn und Kahn und Kahn.
Jeden Tag Kahn. Und Kahn. Und Kahn und Kahn und Kahn und Kahn. Jeden Tag Kahn. Sechzehn Millionen Nachkommen. So. Ja, aber gut. Mein Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Opa hat ja wahrscheinlich auch sechzehn Millionen Nachkommen. Ja, gut. Da wird's schwierig tatsächlich. Aber ja, interessant. Und dann sind die sich ja wahrscheinlich auch alle ähnlich. Die können dann alle, können alle irgendwie dieses Zungending machen oder so oder sind alle immun gegen Aids bei so, da können die es ja verstehen, weil ich verstehe ja eh nicht, warum du deinen Samen nicht mehr in die Welt bringst. Du bist immun gegen Aids, warum gibst du das nicht mehr Leuten zur Verfügung? Die Legende berichtet von 20.000 Kindern bei Genghis Khan, bis bei seinem Sohn Tushi ist man sicherer, er hat 40 Söhne. Okay, 20.000, aber dann kommt unser Kerl … Das war ein Familienfeiern, oder so? Er bringt die Kinder mit? Ja, alle 40. Okay, wir bringen auch unsere Kinder mit. 20.000. Okay, dann brauchen wir die Gartenstühle. Schatz, wir müssen den Tisch ausziehen. Du, wir haben im Schuppen noch ein paar Bänke. Fucking nervig, wenn der Kahn wiederkommt, ey. Und dann die Mutter so mega nervös. Was? Ich hab einen Kuchen. Ich hab einen Kuchen gebacken. Ich könnte jetzt schnell noch ein Tiramisu machen, ja, aber 20.000! Ah, da muss das gute Geschirr, da ruht auch das gute Geschirr raus.
Heinrich, ich gehe in den Keller.
Nicht gehen, ich gehe in den Keller.
Und dann, ähm, ja, ist unser Kerl, ist, ich behaupte, dann stossen die auf 1.000, stossen die auf 2.000 und so, und dann stossen die irgendwann auf Afrika, wo aus irgendwelchen gruseligen Gründen
gibt's so,
es wird so sehr viel Geld bezahlt für
weisse Samen und das ist alles so
schrecklich. Und dann hat er auch
gesprochen mit seinem Kumpel, der da auch teilweise
in die Becher
onaniert hat,
dass sie Afrika
bleachen wollen. Das ist alles
so furchtbar. Und ich bin der Meinung, wir reden da auch von 20.000 oder sowas Kinder. Das heißt, wenn ihr junge Eltern seid und Stefan nett findet, freundlich findet, und in eurem Umkreis, ich weiß nicht genau, wann die Doku erschienen ist, wie ist der Fokusmaschine, wie alt wird die sein, paar Jahre und ja, dann müsst ihr mal gucken, wann dieser Fall so aufgeploppt ist, aber ob eure, weil in Deutschland hat der auch ganz viele Kinder, ob in eurem Umfeld von euren Kindern oder irgendwelche Neffen oder so, ob es da vielleicht so blonde Spenderkinder gibt. Ja, ich meine, das ist die moderne Rom-Com, ne? Also zwei Menschen finden sich irgendwie ganz süss beim Bingo-Abend, irgendwie rufen gleichzeitig Bingo und dann so und dann lernt man sich kennen und dann müssen die sich den Preis teilen.
Ich will so eine richtige RTL-Sit-Rom-Com, so wahnsinnig süss, wahnsinnig süss und dann cute meet und dann geht's natürlich, passt nicht, geht nicht auseinander, am Ende finden sie sich und landen im Bett, großes Finale und dann kommt der Typ, klopft an die Tür und sagt Das ist dein Bruder! Cut! Cut! Harter Cut! Harte Werbung! Und danach kommt nichts mehr, nur noch Werbung und die Leute bleiben trotzdem dran. Aber das ist eine moderne Komödie. Aber wirklich so Alexandra Neldel? Spielt die noch? Ja. Gut, sagt mir Zeitgenösserisch, deutsche Schauspieler. Neldel, spielt die noch? Gut, sagt mir zeitgenössisch, deutsche Schauspieler. Ja, Oliver Wnuck. Warum die akrobischen Namen? Das ist die These vom Anfang, die Neldel. Ja, oder halt nicht Du bist meine Schwester, sondern Du bist meine Tochter. Cut! Cut! Whenever, whenever, whenever meet together, oder was tatsächlich auch ein guter Song wäre für einen Abspann ist. Alte Daten, ich will sie nicht mehr sehen, Alte Daten jetzt als Single verfügbar. Geht auf thethe.com.com. Denn wir treten auf.
Obi Regensburg am 16.
Oktober von 14
bis 14.15 Uhr treten wir
auf beim Obi auf dem
Parkplatz. Ah, dann sehe ich hier
Avignon.
In Südfrankreich.
Da gibt es so ein Fischereifest in so einem
kleinen Dorf, das heisst
und dort treten wir auch auf und zwar
von 16.20 Uhr
Vielen Dank. Frankreich, Südfrankreich. Richtig, genau, da gibt es so ein Fischereifest in so einem kleinen Dorf, das heisst Chemin, und dort treten wir auch auf, und zwar von 16.20 Uhr bis 16.25 Uhr. Innsbruck sehe ich hier auch, Innsbruck. Genau, Innsbruck, da auf Metzgerfest, Kulturhaus beim Metzgerfest, da haben wir den Slot bekommen um 8.16 Uhr bis 8.26 Uhr. Also da müsst ihr früh aufstehen. Warum diese Slots? Wenn ihr da reinkommt. Wir haben nicht so viele Songs. Wir haben keine Daten. Wir haben keine Daten, wir haben USB-Stick. Das ist der gleiche Song. Na, es ist nicht ganz, sondern der Anfang ist gleich. Die Idee von unserem, wir verstehen uns als Baum. Wer ist ihr eigentlich? Marco und ich. Marco? Wir wollten noch eine Band gründen. Ja, aber du hast in so wilden Tonarten gespielt. Ich wollte nur einen Akkord mehr. Wir haben improvisiert. Ihr habt drei Akkorde, ich wollte vier Akkorde. Du hast improvisiert damit irgendwie septatonisch und so. Nein, das ist einfach der vierte Akkord. fucking weit über uns und wir wollten nur so, ja okay, wie wär's mit Ja, der Song Ja, das war ja auch unser Song. Beim ersten Mal klappt's nicht, drehen um. So, ne? Da geht der sich ja rein, USB-Stick. Ja, ich weiß, den Song haben wir zusammengeschrieben. Wie gesagt, Innsbruck und Wernersheim, auch da beim Hagebaumarkt auf dem Parkplatz, zwischen 18 Uhr und 18 Uhr vier. Wieso der Aufritt in Avignon? Den haben wir durch Umwege bekommen, tatsächlich, haben die sich gemeldet, von sich aus. Vielleicht denken die ihr seid das Anderes, the the. Das Problem ist, auf Französisch heisst the the, was sehr versaut ist. Das heisst, Tee, tee, tee. Ja, aber tee, tee ist auch umgangssprachlich für eine gewisse... Ah, für Titten. Naja, also wenn du, sag ich mal, deinen... Titten Florentin. Also wenn du jetzt nicht klassischerweise, sondern eher obenrum. Ja, okay. Ich finde es einfach mega uncool, dass ihr einfach dieses Bandprojekt gestartet habt, alleine. Das ist irgendwie so seltsam, weil die meisten Bands brauchen ja sogar noch drei.
Es sind nur Marco und ich. Ihr habt keinen Schlagzeuger.
Nee, brauche ich ja Schlagzeuger.
Sie braucht den Schlagzeuger.
Ja, ich habe auf der App, wir haben eine ganz tolle App.
Wie App?
Wir haben eine ganz, ganz tolle App.
Garage Band.
Du machst so Duft, Duft, Duft, Duft, Duft, Alte Daten.
Ah, das ist der andere Song? Ja, der ist ein bisschen perkussionslastiger. , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , , Kappen-Ohrwurm. Kommt nach Avignon. Drucker Treiber. Ohne ihn geht es nicht weiter, Drucker Treiber. Ja, guck mal, man kommt rein, das ist da da, das ist da da, das ist genau das Dutzigling. Jetzt habe ich Angst, dass es erfolgreich wird. Ja, okay, wir nehmen dich mit auf die Tour. Du kannst ja vor, bevor wir auftreten, kannst ja ein Salto machen oder so. Ich will auch Schlagzeug spielen. Das Einzige, was ich jetzt sagen möchte,
wenn ihr euch entscheidet, mit Stefan Tietze
jetzt ein Kind zu zeugen, über seinen
Samenversand. Das hast du schon mal gesagt.
Über seinen Samenversand
stefanspritz.de,
würde ich euch bitten, wenn ihr mit Stefan
jetzt ein Kind kriegt, nennt es nicht Florentin.
Stefan.spritz.
Das ist einfach
strange. Klingt wie ein Sommergetränk. Aber es ist das Gegenteil. Es ist wirklich das exakte Gegenteil. Nicht zu wechseln mit Stefan Spritzt. Das ist die Impfkampagne, die leider komplett brach liegt tatsächlich. Da wollte ich ein bisschen was gegen diese Corona-Impfgegner-Geschichte machen, Stefan Spritz. Jetzt wird abgespritzt, du warst eigentlich auf allen Plakaten zu sehen, mit einer riesigen Spritze in deinem Schritt. Das sah nur so aus. Das war eine komische Kampagne. Es sah nur so aus. Ja, eigentlich hattest du sie in der Hand, aber es war halt genau... Warum würdest du so von der Seite fotografieren? Nee, das ist die Idee von ein Arzi-Fotograf. Er hat dieses starke Gegenlicht und da war halt diese Wand hinter mir und dann sah es halt so aus wie ein Phallus. Ja, aber das muss man doch sehen. Man guckt das doch vorher durch, oder nicht? Nee, ich habe eher so geguckt, ob ich die Augen auf hatte. Das war das Problem, dass ich nicht immer... Für den meisten hatte ich die Augen zu. Ja, das ist... Mann, ey. Das ist oft die Augen zu. Immer wenn das so gegen Stefan spritzt, das war so eine gute Aktion. Du hast leider tatsächlich oft die Augen zu. Letztens habe ich ein witziges Auto gesehen. Das war so ein Auto, das so ganz hoch war. Und dann habe ich gesagt, Stefan, bitte schock mal. Und du so, ich hatte ja die Augen zu. Hatt ich eine Minute lang die Augen zu. Stefan, warum musst du, also ist das ein Blinzeln so lange oder warum, Stefan, warum machst du die Augen so lange zu? Ich ruhe sie aus. Man hat immer das Gefühl, du würdest nicht zuhören oder würdest wegschlafen. Was du nicht verstehst. Weißt du, wie oft du am Tag blinzelst? 16.000. Seit du diesen Laptop bei diesem fucking Gewinnspiel gewonnen hast, bist du wirklich jedes Mal. Diese Sitcom-Folge, Stefan mit dem Laptop. Am Ende muss er den, das stören die anderen nehmen.
In jedem Gespräch.
Sehr gut, 14.400 Blinzler Plotag.
Seid ihr die Zahnspange bei diesem fucking Gewinnspiel gewonnen hast.
Nein, nein, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Das Beispielbild ist ein Asiate.
Ja, und?
Deswegen, ich habe dann irgendwie gerade mich versprochen, Plotag gesagt.
Was der Fuss? Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Das Beispielbild ist ein Asiate. Ja, und? Deswegen, ich habe dann irgendwie gerade mich versprochen, habe Plothaak gesagt. What the fuck? Wow. Das ist so ein Inherited Racism. Nein! Das ist nicht fantastisch. Nein, es ist interessant. Meinst du... Das Beispielbild ist ein Asiate aus der Sendung mit der Maus und ich sage, wir blinzeln, sehr gut, Florian, niemand blinzelt, vierzehntausend vierhundert Blinzler pro Tag. Du hast direkt rassistisch das R durch L ersetzt. Meinst du denn, jeder Versprecher ist letztlich durch Rassismus zu erklären? Eine unterbewusste Rassismusentscheidung, ja.
Also 16.000, du warst sehr nah dran, dran und ... Aber was mich interessiert ...
Nee, und deswegen blinze ich so lange.
Weil ich hab gesagt, das ist mir zu viel.
Weißt du, wie viel Energie du verschleuderst, verschwendest, mit 16.000 Blinzen am Tag?
Stell dir mal vor, du hängst ...
Ich mach drei lange.
Aber jetzt mal realistisch gesehen.
Du hängst, sagen wir mal, fünf Gramm an jedes Augenglied. So. Lied. Und mit jedem Blinzeln bewegst du fünf Gramm. Deines? Augenglieds. Und ganz langsam. Ne, sag das mal ganz langsam. Augen.
Augenglied.
Bustabier mal Augenlied.
Augen.
Glied.
Augenglied.
Da ist ein Begege drin.
Stell dir vor, an jedem Augenglied hängt fünf Gramm.
Und mit jedem Blinzeln bewegst du fünf Gramm hoch. Sechzehntausend mal fünf. Ja, aber dann kriegst du so sehr starke Augenglieder. Du verbrauchst wahnsinnig viel Chorin. Da brauchst du keine Kaliburin. Klar, guck mal, das ist Bleifarbe. Wir verkaufen Bleifarbe, wir haben noch keinen Markennamen, ist jetzt egal. Das ist Podcast-Ufo, wenn ich nicht schlecht. Okay. Nee, das ist eingängig, die kennen die doch sehr spannend. So, und dann stell dir vor, Bleiwimperntusche. Wimperntusche, ist das das richtige Wort? Ne, Lidschatten meine ich. Das, was man auf die Augen... Ah, wie heisst das? Wie heisst das, was man drauf macht? Lidschatten. Ah, ah, okay, ja gut. Keine weiteren Fragen. Und ich nick der Jury zu. Die Entscheidung liegt bei euch. Das wäre ein Closing Statement. Am ersten Verhandlungstag. Jetzt sind ihr dran. Und da ist Blei drin, Bleifarbe, und jedes Mal, wenn du blinzelst, verbrauchst du Kalorien.
Auch nur ein Kalorie pro Blinzelschlag.
Du hast 16.000 Kalorien pro Tag verbrannt. Das ist enorm.
Das ist wirklich enorm.
Das ist enorm.
Dann muss man wirklich, mein Grundumsatz ist 3.000.
Ja, also auf 19.000. Das ist gefährlich, dann sterbe ich. Nee, du bist rank und schlank innerhalb kürzester Zeit. In kürzester Zeit bist du rank und schlank. Aber wenn man jetzt Blinzeln zählt, wird dann das Schlafen auch als ein Blinzeln gezählt, ein langes. Oder zählt das nicht? Wenn man das Auge zumacht und für den Tag nicht mehr auf, war das dein letzter, dann war der letzte Blinzler bereits getan.
Aber zählt es denn für den Tag, an dem man einschläft oder für den Tag, an dem man aufwacht?
Nein, es ist kein Blinzler.
Für welchen Tag zählt es?
Nicht mehr.
Das ist der erste Blinzler des Tages.
Ja, aber ich habe Angst, dass sie das zweimal zählen pro Tag.
Ich weiss, dass die Angst ist, weil 14.400 recht als gering einzuschätzen. Ich bin ein wissenschaftlich präziser Mensch. Nee, pedantisch. Nee, weil irgendwann kommt, nee. Wir im Büro sagen, wir sind pedantisch anstrengender Mensch. Es ist auch beide, wie die Sache ausgeht. Ich schaue in zwei Wochen, schaue ich die Tagesschau. Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. So, und dann heisst es die Nachrichten. Herzlich willkommen, schönen guten Abend zur Tagesschau. Eine aktuelle Studie hat ergeben, dass die Menschen 2024 ungefähr 12 Prozent häufiger geblinzelt haben als noch im Jahr 2023. Krieg. So, und dann denkt man, ja, Moment, aber was habt ihr für Daten, was habt ihr für Daten?
Alte Daten!
Krieg.
Das ist die Vorstellung, das generische Krieg. In welcher Welt ist das aufmacht? Krieg. So, und dann hast du nämlich ein Problem, wenn es steigt und schwankt. Das ist immer das Problem mit Daten. Ich bin der Meinung, es ist egal, ob Sie, mehr oder immer Sie sind, den letzten Blinzler des Tages als den ersten werden, von mir aus auch zweimal zählen. Ich weiss, die Angst hast du? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht, nicht, lieber weniger als mehr. Wie würdest du es machen? Ich würde sagen, dass der, der, wenn man es zumacht, und ich würde jedes Auf, das ist doch die Regel, jedes Aufmachen des Auges als Blinzler werden.
Aber kein Aufmachen ohne Zumachen, Stefan. Da speisst sich die Schwatze in den Gans. Nein, ich weiss, da schmeisst sich die Schwatze in die Gans. Aber das ist gut, weil so vermeidest du nämlich den Irrtum, dass es zweifach gezählt wird für beide Tage. Ja, ich weiß. Mich würde ich mal interessieren, ob Menschen, die viel Lidschatten tragen, mehr Kalorien verbrauchen pro Tag als weniger. Und die haben ja auch noch so Augenbrauen, Fakie Augenbrauen. Lash. Eyelashes. Sehr gut. Ja. Ja, Eyelashes. Ja, High-Eyelashes. Und je mehr du im Gesicht hast, ich spreche von Rouge, ich spreche von Wimperntusche, ich spreche von Lippenstift. Ja, klar, da muss überall Blei rein, da muss überall Bleistaub rein. Ich rede jetzt von Staub, denk jetzt nicht an so einen Barren oder so, ich rede von Bleistaub, dass du den wirklich so zermahlen kannst mit den Fingerspitzen. Das musst du überall rein und dann hast du ein richtig schweres Gesicht und hast du über den Tag, du trainierst ja auch die Gesichtsmuskeln richtig krass damit. Ich glaube, ich glaube, es braucht eine Abnehmer-Lotion. Blei-Tape. Geil. Aber so, was man so hat, also Sportler haben das ja manchmal am Rücken oder so.
Das macht er auf der Oberschenkel so Blei-Tape.
Supergeil.
Das finde ich wirklich nicht schlecht.
Super.
Oder sowas wie Handschuhe.
Du trägst Handschuhe, die halt ... Also Sportler haben das ja manchmal am Rücken oder so. Das macht auf der Oberschenkel so Bleitape. Super geil. Das finde ich wirklich nicht schlecht.
Super.
Oder sowas wie Handschuhe.
Du trägst Handschuhe, die halt einfach so 200 Gramm schwer sind.
Super.
Und die hast du den ganzen Tag an.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt eh schon die Armschienen.
Ah, die Geschichte.
Und dann bist du den ganzen Tag.
Wie geht es deinen Arm?
Spürst du deine Arme wieder?
Ich spüre meine Arme, ich habe ein bisschen Bezug zu meinen Armen verloren.
Ich hatte ja Verdacht auf Karpaltunnelsyndrom, weil meine Hände beide in einer Nacht eingeschlafen sind, nacheinander, Schichtsystem, erst die linke Hand eingeschlafen, dann die rechte Hand eingeschlafen. Da ist was schief gelaufen, weil sonst war immer zumindest eine Nacht wach, eine Hand wach. Und dann war ich bei der Handärztin und habe zwei Armschienen für Karpal- Manologin bekommen und trage die jetzt immer. Moment, was sind das? Du hast Armschienen bekommen? Armschienen bekommen, ja. Du musst die so mit Klettverschluss kletten. Ganz ehrlich, das ist der absolute Horror, weil dass du so ein Problem hast, was so ein bisschen wie so ein geckiges, lustiges, ah mein Arm schläft ein nachts Problem begann, dann gehst du zu einer Ärztin und die sagt, sie bekommen jetzt einfach Schienen. Ja, ja. Ist für mich Horror. Ja, aber ich finde es ganz gut, weil man gewöhnt sich super schnell an und die Idee ist, dass das Handgelenk sich nicht mehr abknicken kann. Du, das ist das Problem. Das ist das Problem. Und anscheinend habe ich viel so mit so einer ... Du schläfst wie ein Kätzchen. Wie ein Kätzchen oder wie diese Gottesanbeterin, die da so krass die Handgelenke beugt. Süss auch.
Sehr, sehr süss, das hat die Ärztin auch gesagt.
Die hat mir auch über die Wange gestreichelt und alles.
Das war alles auf einer guten Ebene, hat mir alles gut gefallen.
Klingt nicht mehr so gut.
Aber dann war eben die Armschiehen.
Und das Problem ist ja, ich habe das ja schon mal, glaube ich, hier im Podcast vorgestellt,
ich spiele ja jeden Abend Army.
Was ist das?
Das ist, ich richte den Unterarm auf. Das ist eine Übung, das teilt deine Therapie, oder das ist dein privates Vergnügen? Ich stelle mir immer eine Frage. Kann man wirklich die Kontrolle über einen Körperteil komplett aufgeben? Normalerweise kontrollieren wir alle unsere Körperteile ständig. Kann man wirklich sagen, Arm schlaff. Geht das wirklich? Und ich glaube, nein, es geht nicht. Und was ich mache, ist, ich stelle den Unterarm, also kann man auf dem Tisch auch mal nachmachen. Ich verstehe dein Problem nicht mehr so richtig. Also pass auf, stell dir mal vor, du stellst deinen Arm auf dem Tisch auf, ja, also dein Ellenbogen liegt auf dem Tisch und der Unterarm und die Hand senkrecht nach oben. Du machst so eine Haiflosse nach oben. So. Und jetzt sagst du drei, zwei, eins und du machst die Hand schlaff. So. Hand schlaff nur. Hand schlaff. Du hast Arm schlaff gemacht. Hand und Arm schlaff. So. Und jetzt ist die Frage, hast du wirklich schlaff gemacht oder nicht? Nein. Oder hast du, so und jetzt nehme ich mal die Hand und mache sie mal einen Zentimeter nach links. Und dann mach wieder Schlaf. Und jetzt ist die Frage … Fällt der Arm anders? Fällt der Arm oder dadurch, dass du willst, dass er anders fällt, lenkst du ein bisschen? Ja, ja. Mach es anders. Klar. Die völlige Erschlaffung ist eine Erfindung von denen da oben. Ja, genau, absolut. Genauso sehe ich es auch. Und jetzt ist natürlich das Problem mit der Armschiene, ist es jetzt natürlich noch schwerer, weil jetzt sozusagen da noch so Kleinteile verloren gegangen sind. Weil teilweise, wenn du es wirklich schlaff machst, dann schlackert die Hand auch wirklich so rum. Und dann denkst du, das kann nicht sein. Weil das Problem ist nämlich, du willst, dass es willenlos aussieht und dadurch wird es wieder bewusst.
Schlechtes Schauspiel. Du kannst nur schauspielen. Das ist das Ding. Dadurch wirkt es nicht echt. Aber so, und dann stören nicht die Armschienen beim Schlafen. Die Armschienen machen jetzt bei meinem nächtlichen Army-Ritual, die stören jetzt natürlich. Dabei, okay, bei Army, aber stören die beim Schlafen. Du bist sehr süss, das ist sehr süss alles. beim Schlaffi, nee, das geht eigentlich. Aber ich fühle mich halt so ein bisschen wie Mega Man, weil du hast halt so die Unterarmschienen und ich denke mir so, so Spider-Man, weil Spider-Man hat ja in manchen Comic-Iterationen ja auch so ein Gerät, aus dem er Spinnweben schießt, aus anderen schießt das natürlich. Ja, was ist da eigentlich passiert? Gibt unterschiedliche Auslegungen? Ja, aber das eine ist ein Zauberkünstler und das andere hat eine Superkraft. Ich finde das so lustig. Das ist bei Spider-Man, der eine hat die magische Kraft, weil er von einer Spinne gebissen wurde. Und das ist ja voll geil, kann das ausschliessen. Der andere hat sich ein Gadgety Guy. Das ist so, als wäre Darth Vader so ein Magier. Er hat schon noch die Spidey-Senses und alles und so, aber die Maschine ist tatsächlich auch als Teenager Peter Parker. Warte, warte, als Spidey-Senses, aber das mit den Netzen ist synthetisch. Ich glaube, er kann auch klettern. Ich glaube, er kann auch klettern. Das ist so messy. Ich weiß nicht genau. Es ist so, als wäre Darth Vader, als hätte der so, da hast du so Wind, kriegst du so geblasen an den Hals. Wenn er macht, diese Geste, Würge-Geste und dann kriegt das und dann ist so unangenehm ein bisschen. Er hat so eine Art Taser in der Hand, was er dir dann so an den Hals schießt. Ja, genau. Ach, Darth. Darth. Darthy. Aber kann es sein, dass du ein bisschen Nerd wirst? Wie Nerd? Du wirst ein bisschen nerdy. Wie nerdy. Du hast Magic gespielt. Ich habe Magic gespielt, ja. Kommt dann ein kleiner, haben wir eine Nerdphase? Ach, das ist ja so lustig. Nach Segel? Ich habe dir ein Foto geschickt, wie ich Magic spiele. Ja. Und du hast darauf nicht geantwortet und jetzt im Podcast direkt outgecallt. Na klar. Das ist eine private Information. Na klar. Das widerspricht jetzt meiner Person. Steh zu deinem Nerdtum, steh dazu. Ich habe einem Freund Magic-Karten geschenkt.
Und zwar wollte ich direkt, also er hat es in den Kopf gesetzt, er findet es gerade mega geil.
Und ich dachte, ja komm, vielleicht ist es mega cool, viel Spaß, mach das bestimmt, weil du, mein lieber Freund Florent will, ist ja auch die ganze Zeit am Start damit.
Und dann bin ich in so einen Laden gegangen für sowas, der genauso riecht, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Ja, Heimat.
Es gibt keinen Unterschied. Der Geruch, den ihr euch vorstellt, wenn ihr in den Magic-Laden geht, ist der Geruch. Und dann geht man da rein, super nett, alle waren so freundlich. Und dann habe ich gefragt, was muss ich kaufen, damit wir direkt loslegen können. Eigentlich wollten wir Karten draften. Okay, ja. Also wo dann, da macht man so ein Booster-Pack auf. Und das ist ja eh das Coolste, dieses Rascheln dieser Packs. Da macht man die auf, diese Karten, wie die riechen. Ich war ja früher auch so ein riesen Yu-Gi-Oh-Fan, das erinnert mich. Geruch ist absolut der gleiche. Absolut, ja. Und dann macht man das auf und dann draftet man. Draften heißt, dann geht man das Pack nach und nach rum und hier gab es eine Karte ziehen und keinander, davor wird irgendwie ausgelost, wer zuerst dran ist, whatever. Und dann stellt man sich so ein Deck zusammen, sofern es halt geht, spielt gegeneinander. Ja, und dann haben wir, das ging dann aber nicht, weil wir nur zu zweit waren, dann habe ich so vier so Jump-Starter-Packs gekauft, dass wir direkt loslegen können, jeder zieht zwei.
Und meine Welten waren schwarz-weiss und er war blau-grün und hat auch schon viel mehr Erfahrung, alles gewonnen. Oh, du hast nicht gewonnen? Kein Mal. Kein Mal. Habe es auch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden. Es war für mich ein reines Glücksspiel. Mhm. Ich hab dann die ganze Zeit diese Mana-Karten gezogen und dann aber nicht die Monster,
die ich brauchte. Und dann war, aber es gibt sehr viele Sonderregeln, die ich nicht geschnallt habe. Aber ja, ich habe es gerne gespielt, es war sehr lustig. Ja, Magic schreibt die schönsten Geschichten, sage ich immer. Nein. Fand ich jetzt nicht. Magic schreibt die unglaublichsten Geschichten.
Wie oft spielst du Magic in der Woche?
Aktuell gar nicht.
Streamst du auch nicht mehr Magic?
Nee, nee, aktuell nicht.
Aber du hast super lange gestreamt.
Ich habe super lange gestreamt, ich habe super lange gespielt und ich bin auch recht tief noch drin in Magic, weil es gibt den Podcast, ich glaube aktuell wirklich mein Lieblingspodcast, weil ich spaziere aktuell recht viel und dazu gehöre ich immer den Podcast und der Podcast heißt Drive to Work von Mark Rosewater. Du hast den falschen Podcast. Walk Around soll ich ja nicht hören. Ja, Walk Around. Und das ist der Podcast von Mark Rosewater und das ist der Head Designer von Magic the Gathering. Nein. Und der fährt jeden Tag zur Arbeit und macht auf dem Weg zur Arbeit einen Podcast, in der Zeit, die er braucht zur Arbeit. Und der ist einfach so der König der Nerds. War er das immer schon? Der ist nicht erfunden? Schon lange, wirklich lange Zeit. Nee, er hat es übernommen. Er hat es übernommen, aber er ist wirklich schon lange Zeit Headdesigner und der erzählt halt wirklich immer ein Thema aus der Geschichte und es ist so kleinteilig, aber so schön. Also der macht eine Folge über nur den Rahmen von Magic-Karten, nur den Rand. Fantastisch. Und dann ursprünglich war die Idee, dass beim ersten, also die Karten werden ja reprintet, also wenn du im ersten Set hast du die Karte und im zweiten Set taucht sie wieder auf, dann sollte der Rand eine andere Farbe haben. Ja. und dass es sozusagen sich abhebt. Und dann irgendwann wurden aber die so viel Wert, die Alten, dass man irgendwann gesagt hat, nee, das funktioniert nicht, das ergibt keinen Sinn und dann wurde es wieder geändert und so weiter. Wir werten die Währungen ab, wir werten Weltwährungen ab. Und es gibt tausende verschiedene Themen und wirklich ins kleinste Detail hinein. Und der Mark Rosewater ist einfach ein fantastischer Geschichtenerzähler und unglaublich guter Designer. und deswegen höre ich da immer gerne rein. Magic schreibt die besten
Geschichten. Magic schreibt die besten Geschichten, absolut.
Nee, ich muss sagen,
Was hast du erlebt? Welches Abenteuer hast du
erlebt? Also erst mal, was mich irritiert, diese ganzen
Welten und dann gibt es ja auch so
Herr der Ringe Karten,
so Herr der Ringe Welt,
aber dann habe ich in meinem Billow Jumpstarter
Booster so diesen
Schrott gebastelten Wüterich, einfach so einen Schrottmann, so ein grosser Golem-Mann, Wüterich heisst der. Ja. Und dann kann der aber, kann der so interagieren, theoretisch, mit so Karten aus dem Herr-der-Ringen-Kosmos. Das gefällt mir gar nicht. Ah, okay. Das ist auch in der Magic-Community-Kontrovers aufgenommen worden, als das eingeführt wurde. Da habe ich Fiktionenprobleme mit. Das greift mir dann einfach zu sehr ein. Aber ansonsten schreibt Magic einfach die schönsten Geschichten. Es hat mich, ich schreibe wahnsinnig tolle Geschichten, es hat mich sehr an Yu-Gi-Oh! erinnert. Ich bin natürlich Yu-Gi-Oh! verbunden. Designtechnisch holt mich das nicht so ab. Die Rückseite finde ich sehr schlecht designt, finde ich sehr hässlich, man kennt das. Deswegen, da hat es ja irgendwie so einen Nostalgiefaktor oder so einen ikonografischen Faktor, aber ich finde es nicht so schön. Die eigentliche Idee war, dass mit dem zweiten Set, Arabian Nights, ein anderer Kartenhintergrund, also eine Rückseite eigentlich bestellt werden sollte. Das ist die beste Idee bei Kartenspielen, die Rückseite anders zu gestalten. Genau, das war genau die Idee und deswegen müssen die das bis heute genau den gleichen Kartenrücken machen und da steht auch ein Firmennamen drauf, den Magic nicht mehr benutzt. Also da stand dann zum Beispiel der Name der Druckerei drauf oder der Firma, die den Druck übernimmt. Heute benutzen die das nicht mehr, aber sie müssen es trotzdem draufschreiben, weil sonst könnte man ja bei den Handkarten sehen, was den alten Karten und neue Karten. Also tausend Sachen. Magic schreibt einfach die schönsten Gesch schönsten Geschichten. Weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls, ich würde sagen, das Leben schreibt die schönsten Geschichten. Ach wirklich? Du hast auch gelebt in der Zeit. Nein, ich wollte nur sagen, egal über was, wenn man in so einem Detailgetreue mit so viel Lupe und so viel genau hinschauen über alles berichten könnte, finde ich das schön. Ja. Ich habe auch so einen YouTuber jetzt gesehen, der seine Wohnung gezeigt hat, und der hat wirklich über alle Details gesprochen. Und das finde ich geil. Und genauso finde ich es geil, wenn so jemand über den Rand der Magic-Karten spricht. Ja, ich will Podcasts über Spaltmasse, ich will Podcasts über Farbtöne, Hexcodes.
Oh, ich glaube, da habe ich ein fantastisches Video für dich, weil ich habe einen YouTube-Kanal gefunden von jemandem, der macht Animationen und der erklärt durch die Animation wahnsinnig viel und der erklärt zum Beispiel, wie ein Schiff funktioniert. So ein Schiff der englischen Flotte im siebzehnten Jahrhundert. Und der erklärt jedes einzelne Seil, der erklärt jedes einzelne Brett und alles und wirklich wie die Segel, wo das Segel gelagert wird, was genau unter Deck gelagert wird, wo die Kugeln gelagert werden. Und ich dachte mir, holy shit, und ich habe das eingesaugt, dieses Video, und dann habe ich auf den Kanal geguckt und dann einfach, wie ein U-Boot im Zweiten Weltkrieg funktioniert. Jedes Kabel, wo ist der Sauerstoff eigentlich, Motor, sind die nicht zu laut, weil die müssen direkt neben dem Motor stehen. Wo ist das Periskop, wenn das lang genug ist, um einem die Wasseroberfläche zu gucken, wo wird das überhaupt gelagert? Ist das nicht gar ne ganz lange Stange? Ja. Wahnsinn! Ich habe wirklich, ich habe wirklich Waaah gesagt, als ich den Kanal gefunden habe, weil ich mir dachte, geil, das ist das schönste Gefühl, wenn du was findest und plötzlich merkst, es gibt noch mehr davon. Das ist das beste Gefühl der Welt. Das ist richtig schön. Das gefällt mir sehr. Ja, Details. Da wird es für mich lustig und spannend, weil je mehr Details, Bei Details wird es immer gut. Und vor allem bei Details merkst du einfach mal, was das für fucking unfassbar komplexe, geniale Konstrukte waren, so ein Schiff. Einfach, dass die Segel unabhängig vom Mast sich bewegen können und rotieren und wie das alles gesteuert wird und was man da für Knoten, Techniken und alles. Es ist so krass und die Kanone auch genau, wie das funktioniert und dass die alle zusammen interagieren. Und dann kommt natürlich auch raus, dass man viele Dinge natürlich über Filme falsch weiß, weil du denkst natürlich, dass so ein Schiff gesteuert wird mit so einem grossen Rad. Nicht der Fall. Und den Teil habe ich geskippt, weil tatsächlich wurde so ein Schiff nicht gesteuert mit so einem riesigen Rad, wo du so richtig cool, sondern es ist einfach eine fucking Stange. Will Turner. Das Problem ist, mit dir kann man jetzt nicht mehr unsere Lieblingsreihe Pirates of the Caribbean gucken. Nee, kann ich nicht mehr gucken, weil eigentlich wurde das FM später hängen. Eigentlich dieses Tau war da eigentlich nie. Das hat eigentlich gar keine Funktion. Und eigentlich, weil tatsächlich hängt man so ein Schiff. Mit einer Stange. Du hast eine Holzstange vor dir, so, einfach wie so eine, stellst du dir vor wie so eine Stripperstange. Und dann legst du diese Seite um und dann legst du eine rechts um, wie du willst. Und der steht so halb unter Deck, der Steuermann guckt nur so oben raus an Deck, der guckt aus der Kopf nur so raus. Da wartet der so einen coolen
Hut auf. Der war richtig dumm
und richtig bescheuert. Und Hängematten
wurden auch erst relativ spät eingeführt.
Hat er Holzbein? Nein, hat er nicht. Und es gab auch keinen
Fluch mit Skeletten. Affen?
Und es gab auch keine Elisabeth. Affen auf dem Schulter?
Nein. Keine Elisabeth? Nicht.
Elisabeth! Keine Elisabeth.
Und Hängematten wurden auch erst sehr spät eingeführt.
Die lagen einfach auf Matten
und die mussten sich irgendwo hinlegen,
wo halt Platz war. Die hatten keine festen
Vielen Dank. Keine Elisabeth. Und Hängematten wurden auch erst sehr spät eingeführt. Die lagen einfach auf Matten und die mussten sich irgendwo hinlegen, wo halt Platz war. Die hatten keinen festen Stammplatz, die Matrosen, sondern lagen einfach irgendwo. Und alle schwul. Ja, das sowieso. Wie die Tusker. Ja. Ja, cool. Schaut euch das an, es ist absolut grandios. Ja, finde ich absolut fantastisch. Sowas will ich genau haben. So ein maximales Nischenwissen. Lieb ich. Finde ich ganz, ganz toll.
Und man kann ja nicht so viel meistern. Und ich habe auch gesehen, auch Empfehlungen, Japanese Printmaking, Dave Bow auf YouTube. Ganz fantastisch. Über Papier redet er halt einfach eineinhalb Stunden lang und die Zeit vergeht wie im Flug. Ich habe viele Videos geguckt von der Deutschen Gesellschaft zur Rettung Schiffbrüchiger, die GZDS. Liebe ich, die haben diese Sarr-Schiffe, Search-and-Rescue-Schiffe, die sehen cool aus. Mein Vater hat super lange für die gespendet, voll geil, also es ist ultra, die gibt es einfach, die retten alle Menschen, die ehemliche Unglücke haben in Deutschland, und die gibt's … die sind nur spendenbasiert. Rein spendenbasiert. Das heisst, die ziehen dich aus dem Wasser und dann … gut, dass wir sie gerettet haben. Das war aber anstrengend. Das war aber … und dann hätten sie so einen Hut hin. Wir sind ja komplett spendenfinanziert, ne, und ja, oh ja gut, danke, dass Sie wiederbelebt haben, möchten Sie denn spenden?
Ja.
Also beim Wiederbeleben so, wollen Sie denn vielleicht spenden, nicht spenden schon an ganz viele andere Begriffe.
Oh nein, tot, tot, ich bin doch nicht tot, tot.
Ja, nee, die sind klasse, die machen einen tollen Job und da gibt es so tolle Dokus drüber, so kann man bei YouTube mal ein bisschen gucken. Und vor allem Spenden, sollte man machen. Die gibt es auch in so Läden stehen manchmal, so diese kleinen Schiffchen, das sind so Spardosen in Form eines Schiffchens. Die sind für die, gerade hier in Hamburg, bestimmt müssen die hier im Einsatz die Leute retten.
Falls ihr da arbeitet, sagt mal, was ihr mit dem ganzen Kleingeld macht, bitte. Sagt mal, wie ein Boot funktioniert. Sagt mal, wie ein Boot funktioniert. Also sammelt ihr das Kleingeld irgendwo und bringt es dann zur Bank, wenn ja wohin? Nice. Also, weil ihr müsst euch ja auskennen mit einerseits Seenotrettung, klar, das ist super, aber auch Kleingeldmanager. Das sind deren zwei Säulen. Riesenkompetenz im Seenotretten und wenn nicht so noch grössere Kompetenz darin, Kleingeld wegzubringen. Weil wenn die es bei der Sparkasse machen, verlieren sie bei jedem Gang zur Sparkasse acht Euro. Das habe ich schon mal hier muckiert. Das ist eine Katastrophe. Am Ende spendet ihr an die Sparkasse. Und wenn ich was in Schiff werfe, dann will ich, dass es an die Seenotrettung geht und nicht in die Sparkasse. Die Sparkasse macht ja nur Geld durch die DGZS-Spardosen. Ja, die lachen sich ins Fäustchen. Und glaubt ihr, die spenden das weiter, die Sparkasse? Nee. Kommt schön in Tresor. Was ist eigentlich los mit kontaktlos bezahlen bei der Sparkasse? Merfig. Da muss man mal drüber reden. Letztens gab es ja den deutschlandweiten Ausfall von EC-Karten, Zahlungsmittel. Und ich war im Supermarkt. Ich dachte, das ist die letzten 20 Jahre. Und ich war im Supermarkt und es war wirklich einfach Chaos. Anarchie, die Leute haben irgendwie die Babybrei mit Gläschen aus dem Regal genommen und ausgesaugt, die haben sich mit Zwiebeln beworfen, es war wirklich Anarchie in diesem Supermarkt. In Köln auch neulich. Weil man nicht mit Karten zahlen konnte. In Köln war neulich, da gibt es ja gerade so eine Anschlagsserie, gar nicht lustig und auch nicht schön, ganz schlimme Sachen. Morgens fliegen einfach so Läden in die Luft, bislang wurde niemand verletzt, aber dann gab es so die Aufnahmen, wie dieser Laden brennt, da habe ich auch schon mal einen gekauft. Und dann fliegt der Laden, der Klamottenladen und dann hält oben hält oben so eine Kamera jemand drauf und dann sieht man so einen Menschen, der so reingeht. Ich glaube, der hat sogar nur so eine Boxershorts an. So einen Mann, der reinrennt und dann so Klamotten nimmt und so auf die Strasse wirft. Für alle? Nee, ich glaube für sich. Ich glaube, bei der Laden, da ist eine Bombe hochgegangen. Der Laden hat gebrannt. Und der war unbeteiligt, ist aber reingerannt und hat die Klamotten dann geklaut. Warum hat der nur Boxershirts an? Der dachte sich, perfektes Timing. Ich brauche Kleine. How did I end up in this situation? Aber ich glaube, der wohnte in der Ecke, hat gesehen, fuck, der Laden ist offen. Darauf hat er sein Leben lang gewartet und rennt los. Und dann zieht er so die Hose raus, die so halb brennt einfach. Und dann sagt er, ja gut, besser als mal kostenlos. Besser als nur ein Boxershorts anhaben. Aber sah auf Mies aus, vielleicht auch Sachen angehabt. Aber der ist reingelangen, hat alle Klamotten genommen, auf die Strasse geworfen, wahrscheinlich um sie dann zu klauen. Und das ist so krass, wie sofort so eine, also irgendwo eine Bombe hoch oder so ein, weiß ich nicht mal, was das war, Bombe klingt so riesig. Es war mehr so ein Explosionsding. Ich glaube, wenn man im Wörterbuch nachschaut unter Bombe, dann steht er ziemlich genau. Explosionsding. Ja, aber Bombe klingt so, als wäre es Stadtviertel in die Luft geflogen, finde ich. Aber es war halt nur dieser eine Laden. Ich weiß trotzdem, eine Art Bombe. Er ist jedenfalls... Granate? Rein sowas. Granate trifft es finde ich eher. Granate ist eine Minibombe. Er ist reingegangen, hat er dann alles geklaut. Das ist schon krass, wie sofort so ein, jetzt ist hier so Walking Dead-mäßig, jetzt ist hier alles möglich, so wilder Wespen. Ich glaube, es gibt aber auch einen Schlagmensch, der einfach darauf wartet, dann auch so, der sich dann so Survival-Sachen und genau überlegt und was muss man, der sammelt dann ganz viele Kronkorken, weil das wird ja dann die Währung sein oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Prepper. Und er wartet nur auf den Moment und wenn nur irgendwas Kleines passiert, sofort Zack, Action, sofort Stelzen an, sofort Flammenwerfer umgeschnallt und man wartet einfach drauf. Und er ist direkt wirklich, wie Gott ihn schuf, hin in diesen Laden. Gott schuf ihn als Prepper. Mit Boxershow. Also religiöse Menschen glauben ja, dass der Mensch von Gott so perfekt geschaffen wurde als Prepper. Ja, wie die Arche Noah. Die Arche Noah, Noah war ein fucking Preppy. Ja, ist Noah der Arche Preppy. Ja, der Arche Preppy. Der Arche Preppy. Preppy? Der Archetyp. Ja. Weißt du, das ist ja genial. Ja. Weil er hat doch die Arche dann. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich verstehe schon. Ist auch ein Programmtitel von Bodo Wartke. Der Archetyp? Ja, Noah war ein Archetyp. Gut, gut, dass wir die Gangs zumindest crediten, die Autoren, die Autoren des Podcasts. Ja. Danke, Bodo. Bodo ist jetzt schon seit fast fünf Jahren, glaube ich, Teil des Autorenteams dieses Podcasts. Vielen Dank an der Stelle. Die, ja, aber das finde ich gar kein schlechter Vergleich. Aber im Prinzip werden Leute damals gesagt haben, das ist doch ein Schaden mit der Seeflut. Wie wird so eine Arche gebaut? Also, welche Knoten genau? Also, ich bräuchte ein Video, das mir genau erklärt, weil es ist ja nicht leicht. Du musst dir überlegen die Giraffen. Stelle ich die ganz oben an Deck, damit die Hälse hochgehen? Oder stelle ich die gerade ganz unten hin, damit die Hälse durch die Decke durchgehen? Die können auch ganz unten sein, weil deren Kopf ist ja dann auch über Wasser. Also sagen wir mal, du bist halt jetzt irgendwie so ein Pferd und stehst auf dem Mitteldeck. Und du hast ein Loch im Boden deines Zimmers und in der Decke. Und da geht so der Mittelteil des Giraffenhalses durch. Und du lernst die Giraffe aber nie kennen. Also die wird oben gefüttert. Die wirkt wie Säule. Also die wirkt wie Einrichtung. Und dann, wenn die dann aussteigen, angekommen sind, dann das Pferdepaar geht dann mal zu den Grafen und sagt, Schatz, ich rede nicht. Schatz, nee, lass mal kurz. Schatz, ich spreche die mal an. Nee, lass mal kurz. Nee, Schatz, wir sind jetzt monatelang mit der im einen Zimmer gewesen. Ich glaube, wir können die doch mal auch ansprechen. Die hat uns nie gesehen, nur weil wir sie gesehen haben, dass sie uns gesehen hat. Aber ich fühle mich ja schon jetzt ein bisschen verbunden. Das ist ja wie eine Reise. Wieso denn verbunden? Ich habe sie ihr als Einrichtung wahrgenommen. Das finde ich jetzt aber zu viel. Ich meine, als sie Husten hatte, haben wir das wirklich mitbekommen. Ja. Da haben wir mitgelitten auch. Ja, ich fände es ein bisschen offensiv, dass du ihr die ganze Zeit den Hals gekrault hast. Das konntest du ja nicht deine Hände davonlassen.
Bis du hast gehofft, dass sie wieder krank wurde. Das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht. Also ich konnte ja auch die Finger von dir jetzt nicht lassen. Also das muss man auch mal sagen. Das stimmt. Also ich sag mal so, ich sag mal so, also ich sag mal, der Neuaufbau der Pferdebevölkerung wird schnell gehen mit uns. Und dann wie so ein Stadion, so eine Stimme aus. Mama, Papa, so eine Million Nachkommen, Hunger, Hunger, Hungerlob. Da hat neulich jemand ein Video gemacht, wie er so vorm Olympiastadion in Berlin stand. Und drin haben die Leute so einen Fangesang gemacht, so Hörter, Hörter. Und es klang, man hat nicht genau verstanden, was sie gesagt haben, und es klang, er hat gesagt, es klingt wie die, so müssen sich Frodo und Sam gefühlt haben, als sie vom Mordor standen, weil genau so klang, da hat so eine Horde Orks drin, ist die so, rufo, härter, härter, härter, harter, str, härter, was nochmal, die Orks haben nur, und Sam die ganze, noch mal, was sei die, Pfanne, Pfanne, sagt ihr? Die Orks haben nur fucking Werder Bremen angefeuert oder sowas. Orks würden Werder Bremen wählen. Nein, nein, Erby Leipzig. Ja, das ist der böse Verein. Haben die als Zeichen auch so ein brennendes Auge? Ja. Das brennende Auge. Wie weit bist du mit The Rings of Them Powers? The Rings of Them Powers. Ich bin ja kein Fan, kein Fan, kein Fan, I hate it. Ich gucke trotzdem, ich gucke jede Folge. Und das ist so lustig, wenn man sagt, wenn man mit Leuten spricht und sie fragen, guckst du gerade Rings of Power, wo war bist du? Und ich sage, ich bin bis ganz am Ende, wird aktuell. Und dann wollen sie natürlich mit dir darüber reden, wie toll sie die Serie finden. Und sie sind immer irritiert, dass ich sage, ich hasse diese Serie. Wirklich? Ja, weil die, weil natürlich, wenn man es zu Ende guckt und wenn man fragt, guckst du es auch? Und ich sage, ja, und dann natürlich kommt die Erwartungshaltung, dass man es gut findet, sonst würde man es ja nicht zu Ende gucken. Ich gucke jede Minute dieser Serie, stimmt nicht, so manche Parts gebe ich einfach brutal vor, weil die so schlecht sind, aber ich will einfach in dieser Welt sein, ich will die Leute sehen, ich will Zwerge sehen, ich will Elben sehen, aber es ist schrecklich, es ist eine schreckliche Serie. Es ist ganz merkwürdig, diese Serie anzuschauen, weil sie wirkt ein bisschen wie eine Serie, die Aliens gemacht haben, irgendwie so. Es ist so, es ist so merkwürdig, man kriegt keinen Zugang. Ich denke mir so, weil, ich stelle mir immer vor, so eine Serie oder ein Film ist wie ein Haus. So, ja, du hast eine gewisse Struktur. Das kommt wieder an diesen berühmten Florentin-Vergleich hier, wo man nicht genau weiss.
Du hast eine gewisse Struktur und es geht erstmal darum, steht das Haus überhaupt?
Und dann können wir darüber reden, hat es schöne Wände oder so, aber erstmal steht es.
Weil wenn das Haus zusammenbricht, dann ist ja egal, ob du coole Shots hast oder Musik.
Wenn die Struktur nicht stimmt, dann funktioniert es nicht so.
Du kannst nicht diese Metapher aufmachen, um sie dann zu verlassen. Sag doch, ob sie schöne Wände hat oder so. Ja, ja. Achso, okay. Du kannst sie nicht verlassen, dann lass sie sein. Dann lass das Beispiel Haus weg. Aber jetzt sagen wir mal, der Kameramann wohnt im ersten Zimmer links unten. Okay, ja. Nein, wie gesagt, du vertauscht wieder beide Welten. Und ich habe das Gefühl, bei Rings of Power, das ist eine Serie, das ist ein Haus und du gehst rein und die Tür ist so zehn Zentimeter zu niedrig. Und du denkst dir, Moment, irgendwas ist komisch, aber du checkst es nicht genauso. Du fühlst dich nicht wohl in diesem Haus. Für mich ist es, ich gehe ins Haus rein und denke, ich gucke eine Soap. Ja. Ich gucke eine Soap. Aber es ist auch keine fünftige Soap. Wenn ich eine Soap will, dann Soap mich. Dann Soap mich! Das macht nicht mehr richtig Sinn. Dann gehe ich in die Soap. Dann gehe ich in ein Soap-Zimmer. Verstehst du? Ja, nimm mal aber so Elben weg, Zwerge weg, die ganzen Begrifflichkeiten, die ganzen Namen, Galadriel, weg. Galadriel, Numenor, Elrond, Numenor.or, nimm das mal weg, ne? Ja. Und gibt dir normale Namen wie Alejandro, Alejandro, oder González oder sowas, dann bist du, die Storylines sind einfach eine fucking Soap, so eine südamerikanische Soap. Es ist so schlecht, Und Galadriel ist ja eine uralte Halbgöttin, crazy Frau, die alles gesehen hat. Das hat aber bei TikTok so eine superkrasse, die ist mega drin, sie hat sich darüber auch beschwert und dann hat sie gesagt, die hat so Apokalypsen gesehen. Galadriel, die war, die ist eine, die kennt die ersten Götter, die die Welt erschaffen haben. Und im Buch beschreibt Tolkien sie auch als eine, die, wenn man ihr in die Augen guckt, wie Engel, haben Menschen Angst. Menschen haben Angst, wenn man ihr in die Augen guckt, weil die glänzen so krass und sie sind so übermenschlich. Und in der Serie ist sie einfach eine fucking Menschfrau.
Dussel-Dussel-Kopf.
Ein Dussel-Kopf.
Ein sturer Dussel-Kopf.
Ich möchte jetzt mal eine ganz kritische Frage stellen.
Müssen Sequels ... Nochmal?
Komm nochmal rein.
Stopp.
Das sind die Momente, wo man sich nicht versprechen darf, die man dann so hart reingeht und so. So, ich möchte jetzt mal eine wirklich kontroverse Frage stellen. Kontroverse. Müssen Prequels scheitern? Weil, das Problem ist ja, du kennst ja den Mittelpunkt, du kennst ja Herr der Ringe, und dann springst du in der Zeit zurück. Und Geschichten leben ja von Veränderung. Das heißt, Dinge müssen sich verändern, sodass sie so sind, wie du sie am Mittelpunkt erwartest. Aber du kannst ja ganz woanders anfangen, dass sie verändert sind. Wenn wir die Figuren am Anfang kennenlernen, müssen die ja anders sein, als sie so sein werden, wie wenn wir sie eigentlich schon kennen. Also, wenn du Galateria kennenlernst, muss sie anders sein, als die Figur, die du kennst. Ja, Problem, wir reden ja von einer tausend Jahre alten Frau. Ja, eben, aber grundsätzlich, das war ja dieses Soloproblem mit dem Solofilm von Han Solo, weil du musst ja Han Solo so weit verändern, dass er sich innerhalb des Films dorthin verändern kann, damit er so ist, wie er anfängt bei Star Wars. Und dann schaust du und denkst, das ist doch nicht Han Solo. Aber das ist ja das generelle Prequel-Problem, dass du Dinge verändern musst und die Leute, die es anschauen, wollen eigentlich nichts anderes sehen, als das, was sie kennen. Das ist nicht das Problem. Ich gebe dir komplett recht. Aber wie viele Prequels haben denn wirklich funktioniert? Jetzt sagt nicht Indiana Jones. Ja, Prequels, ja, aber Sequels auch nicht. Und die haben theoretisch das gleiche Problem. Naja, Fast and the Furious 8. Klasse. Ich verstehe diese Aussage nicht so ganz, weil nach der Logik dürften ja auch Sequels nicht funktionieren. Ja, aber bei Sequels kannst du ja die Geschichte weitererzählen. Ja, und? Du kannst sagen, du hast eh nichts Problem, Luke Skywalker, Episode 8. Aber du kannst doch umdrehen. Das ist Luke Skywalker, der hat sich halt verändert. Aber das ist das generelle Problem. Aber die Erwartungshaltung sollte nicht mit der Qualität der Serie zu tun haben oder des Films. Du hast ein Erwartungshaltungsproblem. Aber bei Sequels setzt du ja da an, wo du aufgehört bist. Na und, ist doch egal. Ja, aber du kennst die Figur. Ist doch das egal. Ich gehe doch vom normalen Franchise-Fan aus, der einfach das Gleiche nochmal sehen will, was er schon kennt. Viele Filme haben am Anfang einen Flash-Forward, wo man zeigt, wie es endet. Und dann ist es so ein, wie kamen wir denn in diese Situation, in diese Vertragte-Situation. Und es funktioniert genauso. Nein, ich glaube, es ist kein inhärentes Problem, dass Prequels nicht funktionieren. Du kannst ja auch zum Beispiel einen ganz anderen Charakterstab nehmen. Absolut, das kannst du machen. Und dann treffend zwischendurch auf Kyle Hadriel und man freut sich schon so, wenn man die kennt. Das ist doch mega geil. Ich glaube, das ist auch der bessere Weg, weil Prequel plus Fanservice funktioniert oft nicht, weil die bekannten Dinge, die du zeigen willst, müssen im Prequel ja anders sein. Und das ist ein Problem. Und ich würde dir auch widersprechen, ich bin inzwischen davon ab, dass Charaktere sich immer entwickeln müssen.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen, da bin ich inzwischen nicht mehr so. Also Charaktere müssen sich nicht unbedingt klar in so Major Blockbustern und so, hast ja gewisse Tropen oder so Sehgewohnheiten, die der Film ist, aber es geht auch ohne. Gerade bei sowas, also gerade bei so Rings of Power, niemand guckt das für Charakterentwicklung und die Heldenreise oder keine Ahnung, das ist der Moment, wo, ach, er hat da die Antithese und jetzt wird daraus eine Synthese. Gott sei Dank. Du stellst gerade alles auf den Kopf. Ich würde einfach, ich will die Olifanten sehen, ich will Ottifanten sehen, ich will Olifanten gegen Ottifanten feiten sehen. Die Olifanten sind die schöne Inneneinrichtung in der Küche. Aber damit du die genießen kannst, muss das Haus stehen. Und das merkst du gar nicht. Wenn du ins Haus gehst, wenn du die scheiß dreckigen Kackstorien hast, wenn du ins Haus gehst, denkst du nicht, gut, dass es steht, sondern du sagst dir, oh wow, der Teppich ist aber schön, ah, die Wand ist schön. Aber wenn dir das Haus auf den Kopf fällt, dann kannst du auch die Wand nicht begutachten. Und das ist das Ding, diese ganze Zeug, Charakterentwicklung, Heldenreise, das ist alles die Struktur des Hauses, die du aber nicht mitkriegst, sondern das ist einfach der Hintergrund und du schaust dir die schönen Töpfe an. Aber du stellst eh gerade alles auf den Kopf. Du stellst alles auf den Kopf. Ja, ich denke mir, muss das alles immer so sein, wie es immer gemacht wurde. Gut, okay, du bist Avantgarde. Ich bin nicht Avantgarde. Ich bin gerade mal kurz Avantgarde. Ich bin einfach Standard, ich will einfach, ich will einen Cheeseburger und ich will, dass auf dem Cheeseburger auch ein Gürkchen drauf ist. Nee, aber ich sag dir. Und ich will keinen dekonstruierten Cheeseburger, sondern ich will das Gürkchen haben. Wir sind aber gerade vielleicht gar nicht so weit voneinander entfernt. Vielleicht bin ich der Meinung, dass Prequels ein bisschen Avantgarde brauchen, um geil zu werden. Sei es, man hat nicht die gleichen Charaktere und macht andere und treffen sie auf Galerie. Nimm mal zehn Filme, wo das funktioniert hat. Prequels? Ich dachte doch gerade, dass sie nicht funktioniert haben, das ist ja mein Punkt. Ich finde auch, dass sie nicht funktioniert haben. Gut, dann sind wir uns ja einig. Aber Star Wars 1 bis 3. Ich sage nämlich, müssen Prequels scheitern? Ja. Ich sage, Lösungsansatz, Avantgarde. Und 1 bis 3 ist ein Positivbeispiel für dich, weil die so verrückt sind, dass es wieder funktioniert, 1 bis 3? Nee, ich finde tatsächlich auch noch Storytelling, also man kann sagen, die Politik gefällt dir nicht, die Macher gefällt dir nicht, ist alles so trashig, die ganze Romanz ist nicht so schön erzählt, aber das, da passt ja alles, wo sie dann am Ende sind. Ja. Also natürlich, du kannst, stell dir mal vor, du erzählst dann auch noch die Romanze schön, aber das ist ja jetzt sozusagen am Ende so die Kirsche auf der Sahnetorte. Das kann man ja einfach dann mal schöner schreiben, die Dialoge, und die verlieben sich besser. Aber das ist doch, also wo sie am Ende enden, ist doch, also was sich Story anbelangt, total toll. Es ist schon ein harter Sprung von Obi-Wan Kenobi lässt Anakin mit verstümmelten Körper liegen, damit er qualvoll in der Lava verbrennen soll. Fand ich schon hart. Na und? Zu Episode 4, ach ja, stimmt, der Typ da, das fand ich schon hart. Da, da finde ich, hat man manchmal so das Zaumzeug gesehen. Ja, aber das ist eine Geschmacksfrage, aber es geht so viel ineinander und da ist ja genau das gleiche. Da ist mir doch, ich finde es ja, du weißt ja, wer Darth Vader ist. Du weißt auch, dass Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker ist, den er am Anfang kennen. Du weißt ja immer so, dass die Reise es halt schön erzählt, das scheißegal, klar weißt du, wo er endet, aber das macht das nicht kaputt. Nee, das ist so, das ist so kein Problem. Ich glaube nicht, dass Prequels generell schlecht sein müssen. Aber ich glaube, die Zeit, in der wir leben, ist eine furchtbare Zeit für Mainstream-Blockbuster-Produktionen. Es ist Horror. Was gerade, ich finde, ist alles Horror. Und da müssen wir mal raus. Mit Avantgarde. Hast du eine konkrete Idee? Avantgarde. Avantgarde. Hast du eine konkrete Idee? Joker macht's ja richtig. Joker macht's ja, diese ganzen Joker-Filme, die werden ja so ein bisschen avantgardistisch. Oder Batman oder so. Es gibt ja so kleine Beispiele, wie es gerade passieren kann. Dune ist ja Dune Avantgarde. Super. Ja, gut. Mochte ich sehr, fand ich absolut toll. Ja, da ist halt ein Auteur, da ist ein Auteur, das ist ein Auteur-Kino. Das gefällt mir dann gut wieder. Okay. Dass jemand mit ein bisschen Brains ist. Aber sonst, Rundumschlag. Du hast jetzt einfach mal die komplette Filmszene komplett mit einem Hammer zerdeppert, Stefan. Du hinterlässt nur Scherben. Nee, ich gehe in dein Haus, nimm den Hammer, mach Löcher rein und jetzt verglase ich die Löcher.
Und dann plötzlich habe ich viel grössere Fenster.
Komm viel mal Licht rein.
Aber der Teppich, Stefan.
Der ist jetzt ruiniert. Weil das Ding ist, du räumst
halt auch nicht auf. Du kommst immer rein
und machst deine Sachen und du räumst halt nicht auf.
Das ist das Problem.
Und dann denkt man sich halt, okay, jetzt bist du
mal in Hamburg, man kann dich auch mal einladen, aber dann muss man halt selber aufreiten. Das ist halt auch nicht meins. Ja, aber dein Haus steht, aber es ist halt nicht eingerichtet. Aber es steht. Ja, und das ist erst mal das Wichtigste. Es steht. So heißt die Folge. Aber es steht.
Meine Damen und Herren, das war Stefan Tietze, Filmkritiker, Visionärer und Avantgardist.
Das war Florentin Will, Metaphorist und Konsument.
Bin ich zufrieden mit. Wir freuen uns auf die nächste Woche und wünschen euch bis dann alles Gute.
Kommt gut durch, ihr packt das Augensund durch.
Bis bald, wir habenben ab, tschau!